are you ready for the next Xbox one  update microsoft has a wave of new  features and improvements hitting  tomorrow februari 19th I'm Tony and this  is your gamespot news update first  you'll be able to see who's in a party  before joining if you're trying to avoid  Steve from the bonfire last week it'll  be a lot easier also coming is the gamer  score leaderboard you can compare  numbers now but soon you'll be able to  see who scored the most over rolling  30-day periods you'll also be able to  rearrange pins on the home screen and  even access some of them offline  additional changes are coming to the  activity list suggested friends xbox one  chatpad avatar store and more all  together these changes should make the  things you like to do easier to do Xbox  one's februari update will be available  on friday februari 19th xboxes my kubera  says it's just one of many coming to the  council this year when microsoft  announces the next round you'll hear  about it from gamespot